est aujourd'hui soumise au secret
merci la parole est un monsieur yves
nicolas
mon propos s'adresse à monsieur le
premier ministre il y a trois ans le
président hollande lancé le grand choc
de simplification le 3 février dernier
vous déclariez simplifie et par tous est
nécessaire c'est depuis trois ans notre
mot d'ordre or depuis quatre ans les
français n'ont jamais autant souffert de
la complexité administrative
ce qui devait être plus simple est
devenue encore plus compliquée le
président de la république alors arabe
est une carte maîtresse lors du dernier
remaniement gouvernemental il a placé un
secrétaire d'état à la simplification
il faudra d'ailleurs à jour nous
expliquer ce qu'a fait monsieur placé
pour simplifier la vie des entreprises
et des ménages mais est ce bien
nécessaire face à ce vide cosmique alors
je pensais naïvement que la retenue à la
source allait enfin ça a payé la
totalité vers ses niveaux simplification
nous sommes servis d'abord vous nous
expliquer que pour éviter que les
contribuables qui sont des petits malins
aux profits de l'année 2010 est pour
faire de l'optimisation fiscale le
gouvernement a prévu de prélever en 2018
les revenus exceptionnels perçus l'année
précédente tour de passe passe une année
électorale bien joué mais scandaleux
merci de prendre les électeurs pour des
imbéciles
ensuite vous nous dites que les
entreprises bref déjà la csg qu'elles
peuvent donc aussi bien se charger du
prélèvement de l'impôt sur le revenu
sauf que l'impôt sur le revenu est
individualisé et demandera ton de la
part des entreprises de déploiement de
moyens considérables comme si elle
n'avait que cela à faire merci de
prendre les entreprises pour des
imbéciles enfin monsieur près-midi sais
j'en terminerai par là il est écrit que
pour éviter les problèmes de
confidentialité
les contribuables qui le souhaitent
pourront prendre la responsabilité de
calcul et de verser de leur propre chef
la différence entre le montant de la
retenue la sueur s'opérer et celui du
prélèvement normalement dû alors là
c'est d'une simplicité déconcertante
merci de prendre définitivement les
contribuables pour les imbéciles la
parole est à monsieur christian eckert
secrétaire d'état chargé du budget et
des comptes publics merci monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les députés
monsieur le député vous n'avez pas le
monopole du respect des contribuables ce
que vous auriez pu dire monsieur le
député s'est tout d'abord concernant les
revenus de 2010 est qu'ils ne rentreront
j'amenais
s'agissant des revenus réguliers des
revenus salariés des pensions des
revenus fonciers ils ne rentreront
jamais dans l'assiette de l'impôt sur le
revenu et si et si une disposition a été
prise pour les revenus exceptionnels
c'est pour qu'une petite minorité de
français qui auraient soit des revenus
pilotable c'est le cas d'une très petite
minorité de français soit des revenus
exceptionnels parce que ça peut arriver
dans la vie est bien ses revenus soit
assujetti dans les conditions normales
comme d'habitude en 2018 pour ceux qui
sont perçus en 2010 est s'agissant de la
prétendue complexité pour les
entreprises face aux lions sérieux tous
les gouvernements et particulièrement
celui ci qui ont travaillé sur la mise
en place de la déclaration sociale
nominative qui est un progrès
considérable et qui connaît aujourd'hui
une adhésion massive de la part des
entreprises et bien c'est une ligne
supplémentaire dans ce tuyau
informatique qui permettra les échanges
entre les entreprises et les
administrations
alors si ceci est considéré comme
compliquée je n'y comprends plus rien
enfin s'agissant des avantages qu a
parfaitement décrit michel sapin sur le
prélèvement à la source chaque français
pour aller mesurer et tout seul ce qu'il
y a quelques années sur ses bancs à
droite était favorable au prélèvement à
la source aujourd'hui pour des raisons
politiciennes de circonstance ce
deviennent défavorable et s'y oppose au
moins sur pause quand il vient dans
l'hémicycle alors cela modernité la
simplicité c'est bien de se